y
[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france 24 la leche de los
sueños es el título de la edición número
59 de la bienal de arte contemporáneo
que empezó el pasado 23 de abril en la
ciudad de venecia en italia se trata de
una de las manifestaciones culturales
más importantes del mundo y este año hay
una presencia latinoamericana
significativa nuestra corresponsal en
italia natalia mendoza nos cuenta más
en estos días los canales de venecia
conducen al sur de la serenísima en
donde se dio inicio un evento cultural
mayor la bienal de arte de venecia este
año 79 países están representados entre
ellos varios latinoamericanos en el
pabellón de médicos se presentan obras
con una carga emocional como estas 43
figuras sin cabezas suspendidas en
referencia a los 43 estudiantes
desaparecidos en iguala durante el
gobierno de enrique peña nieto
creo que tiene
una función importante recordar
pero también curar
es necesario hablar de esas cosas y
dejarlas como un marcador en el tiempo
es parte de la cultura de mishima aunque
uno no quiera de esa forma a méxico se
ha vuelto parte de mí para los
organizadores del evento la diversidad
cultural de los latinoamericanos es una
de las fuerzas de esta bienal pensó que
el accionar pienso que la escena
artística en muchos de los países
latinoamericanos es extremadamente
interesante han sido capaces de crear un
panorama muy cohesivo estoy muy contenta
de tener muchos de estos artistas
exponiendo a quirarte hice demos a
artistas originarios de países como
argentina cuba y guatemala el único país
de centroamérica presente en esta bienal
en su pabellón el fuerte es esta obra
monumental una pintura de 7 metros de
ancho christian escobar duró casi un año
creando la artista autodidacta escobar
domina la técnica del hiperrealismo en
esta obra bautizada inclusión que define
como un llamado al respeto de las
diferencias en su país natal
creo firmemente que guatemala es un país
que tiene muchas cualidades y esas
cualidades residen en cada individuo que
es distinto todos somos diferentes la
piensa que esa será manera de una obra
como una obra de teatro en la cual cada
personaje representa una parte
importante del país y poder hacer de
esta forma como una danza porque para mí
guatemala no es es no es exacto es
estática guatemala tiene mucho
movimiento de los 213 artistas que
participan a esta bienal 34 son
latinoamericanos representantes del
pluralismo cultural en uno de los
eventos artísticos más importantes del
mundo
en otros escenarios del lado de la
televisión las producciones
latinoamericanas también encuentran el
éxito la miniserie argentina al rey no
se fue con tres galardones hace unos
días en los premios platino del cine
iberoamericano en esta obra todavía
disponible de netflix seguimos un pastor
evangélico que entra en la carrera
presidencial tras el asesinato de su
compañero de fórmula una serie que se
destaca por su ritmo por una inteligente
construcción del suspenso y para un
elenco sólido tanto de los personajes
principales como de los secundarios otra
producción de netflix y otra serie con
una trama que entremezcla drama tensión
y crimen la colombiana pálpito que sin
ningún mal juego de palabras se ganó el
corazón del público es que los
guionistas jugaron con la realidad de
los carteles de tráfico de órganos y la
ficción de las condiciones de un
trasplante cardiaco para escribir esta
historia de una vida robada y de un
esposo buscando venganza una apuesta que
dio sus frutos ya que palpitó logró
posicionarse dentro de los contenidos
vistos de la plataforma a nivel mundial
otra persona
entonces aquí le tengo una vida
hablamos ahora de música empezando por
un videoclip muy simbólico para el tema
que ustedes desean en el beijing se
estrenó a finales de abril pero el
cantante británico y el rapero
estadounidense lo grabaron en kiev en
ucrania justo antes de que empezara la
guerra la realidad bélica actual da un
otro sabor a las coreografías del
holandés 6 la tucumana y de sus
bailarines llenando las calles con sus
saltos y sus giros y en cherán tomó la
decisión de mandar el dinero generado
por las visualizaciones en youtube a una
asociación humanitaria de ucrania
[Música]
lejos de ucrania da el franco congoleño
that you y la caboverdiana ya dijeron
kinshasa como escenario del videoclip de
su nueva canción toco toco un tema
incluido en el próximo álbum de daliu
cullinan a que se estrenará el 13 de
mayo
[Música]
nos despedimos con la luz cálida y el
olor a mar del último videoclip de la
colombiana carol y su canción provenza
rinde homenaje a su barrio de medellín
con un vídeo donde solo aparecen mujeres
y grabado en la paradisíaca isla de
lanzarote en las canarias gracias por su
confianza y cuídense
pero todo que no sé de ti
estoy feliz
pues está para vivir bien el tiempo no
salvación
[Música]
creo que no